Ciao Arrivo
oggi giocheremo nuovamente a Pofi
playtime ma Proveremo gli errori più
divertenti anche detti in inglese Glitch
Che cosa sono i Glitch di errori
Praticamente sono gli errori che ci sono
nel gioco che succedono base a varie
cose ad esempio se Sfotti qualche
oggetto se fai qualcosa di diverso
dovrebbe succedere qualcosa di strano di
proprio succedere questi errori o almeno
troveremo un po' Ma se questo video
raggiungerà 10.000 mi piace fare un
secondo episodio in cui proviamo altri
errori di Poppy Play Tumblr Quindi mi
raccomando la torre 48 prendete i
Popcorn Mettetevi comodi e iniziamo con
il primo blitz Allora il primo Glitch
consiste in questo se volete ovviamente
potete provarli anche voi scrivete nei
commenti che cosa è successo per fare in
modo che funziona il primo Blitz
dobbiamo mettere una scatola davanti
all'entrata in cui passa quindi stiamo
nella fabbrica Ecco qua Vitalia Già
posizionato due scatole cosa succederà
ad dovrebbe inciampare in queste scatole
Ok riposizione amo le scatole perché
vitelli ha scalzato dall'altra parte per
prendere le scatole basta usare una di
quelle mani bioniche allungabili che
abbiamo preso durante il gioco Ecco cosa
stiamo attirando la scatola e dobbiamo
posizionarla esattamente all'entrata
così sicuramente Anch'io Speriamo non
vedo l'ora di vederlo cadere e gli
stampare 40 Troppo divertente Allora
vediamo un po'
anche l'altra scatola per sicurezza Non
si sa mai che scrivi quella scatola
quindi metteremo un'altra scatola lì
così sicuramente
ho sbagliato
Ok abbiamo fallito il primo Glitch
riproviamo e cerchiamo di posizionare
meglio la scatola Vediamo se riesco a
prendere la scatola gigante prima tirare
un calcio sta funzionando
Ok abbiamo posizionato la scatola
gigante che ora posizioniamo questa
piccola e speriamo che questa volta la
trappola funzione che inciampi e che
cada e mi è venuto un dubbio che dubbio
io come farò a scappare Ok ragazzi Forse
ci siamo guardate la scatola blocca il
passaggio te lo faccio un po'
dai già fai
avvocato la scatola
aiuto Dov'è il tunnel
secondo Glitch vediamo che questo
secondo Glitch funziona o te l'hanno
sistemato spero di no per il secondo
errore quiz dobbiamo prendere le scatole
sistemarle qua vicino al cancello perché
tra poco scoprirete il perché abbiamo
posizionato le scatole dovete mettere
una grande e una piccola per potersi
salire sopra e ora non ci resta che ci
vediamo
il cancello si è chiuso
Dov'è finito dov'è andato e guarda sopra
attento prima di salire Guarda se se lui
non mi sembra sia qui
questo Glitch questo errore frutto Viola
e cioè mettere le scatole là sotto per
poter salire qua sopra e lui si blocca
però rimane lì a guardarti è molto
inquietante
[Risate]
è sempre lì bloccato sta guardando
si guarda lo sguardo
inquietante
andare a nascondersi dietro ai
macchinari
[Musica]
Praticamente il prossimo Glitch consiste
nel saltare dietro la fabbrica qua
dietro ma sembra che abbiano messo
qualcosa
Ti abbraccio
Ecco perché non si può quindi bisogna
andare qua alla fine poi saltare qua
Ma dove stai camminando stai volando
Wow come possibile adesso
ok sono atterrata Ma questo che cos'è È
un oblò
una volta che chiameremo aghi da qua
dietro dobbiamo
[Risate]
mettere una scatola lì davanti perché
una volta che arriva agli succederà una
cosa incredibile
riproviamo risalto qua
che così ti avvicino vediamo se
riusciamo a tornare
allora non ti resta che mettere le
scatole qua
mi raccomando
OK riproviamo a via Murri Patrizia
Speriamo che funzioni adesso
L'importante è riuscire a salire non
essere presentimenti bisogna
riposizionare la scatola dietro nella
fabbrica abbiamo
arrivato
mamma che gonfia
pensavo di nuovo
[Musica]
[Risate]
dietro
vediamo dove Ecco la nostra trappola la
scatola
Ok proviamo con un'altra scatola
noi Comunque stiamo tutti bene così
dietro
[Musica]
non sapevo
per poco viene proprio da qua che se
prendi la scatola non ti vede possiamo
spostare lo scatolo toccando la scatola
Vediamo che succede
sta guardando a
prenderti
Ciao
via la scatola di riprovare con questo
perché ha fatto sparire la scatola
troviamo
Purtroppo non siamo riusciti a far
funzionare quel Glitch ma vi faccio
vedere questo è quello che sarebbe
dovuto succedere potete vedermi questa
che quindi aghi aghi sarebbe dovuto
volare fuori e andare nel rullo
trasportatore per me è stato super
divertente Purtroppo non siamo riusciti
Ma se voi provate fateci sapere se ci
siete riusciti al prossimo
dovrebbe essere più semplice dobbiamo
entrare nella via di fuga qua però prima
di entrare giriamoci
[Musica]
Glitch ma non sapevo che fosse in Glitch
Cioè ti chiude la porta non c'è a chi
non c'è non c'è
[Musica]
non c'è
Come mai
molto strano come mai ancora non apparso
perché non ci sta seguendo molto strano
questo penso che ti è arrivata senza
dirmi
a pagarlo e non c'è
riproviamo Il click questa volta
dobbiamo girarti molto prima prima che
si chiuda la porta
quindi fuori dalla porta giro ti vediamo
giù sempre libero è vediamo lui dovrebbe
fermarsi
e come un errore doveva fermarsi aghi
invece di prenderti si fermava così
aspettava
forse hanno risolto l'errore
l'aggiornamento troviamo ora l'ultimo
Glitch che è super interessante Speriamo
che funziona che non abbiano risolto
anche questo
dobbiamo andare avanti e dobbiamo andare
fino alla porta del tunnel quella che si
chiude però invece di entrare Dobbiamo
fermarci prima e succederà una cosa
incredibile
[Musica]
sono fatto bene non mi ricordo penso di
andare di qua
Adesso mi devo cucinare Purtroppo non
siamo riusciti a concludere questo
Glitch quello che sarebbe dovuto
succedere a che ora gli passa davanti
noi entriamo nel tunnel ero già qui è
arrivato fra gli aghi riusciamo a uscire
fuori dal gioco ma non ci siamo riusciti
fateci sapere se voi ci siete riusciti
Se avete notato altri errori altri clip
che volete che proviamo scriveteli nei
commenti e ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
cartelline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video